Prince William and Kate Middleton went  back to school on Friday to support  place to be the children's mental health  charity that provides in-school support  and training for emotional well-being  the visit was part of the royal couple's  heads together campaign which is all  about mental health awareness the Duke  and Duchess of Cambridge offered support  to students and then Prince William  offered actual physical support to a  local dignitary vice Lord Lieutenant of  Essex Jonathan Douglas Hughes took a  little tumble and fell over  while greeting at William and Kate the  Prince helped Jonathan get back on his  feet and he looked to be it just fine  the vice Lord Lieutenant of Essex was  all smiles while chatting with the  couple after the incident